my favorite one was the crossbow when
you shot it it had a lot of impact on it
my usually watched the nerf gun
commercials it's like in that army man
voice it's all like yeah well I kind of
like the way it's just shaped like a gun
I think this is the best one my favorite
toy was this bow and arrow because you
can put it put the ammo in so many
different places I don't like pink by
itself because it's just like pink I
wouldn't pick the colors but I like how
it shoots so that kind of evens it out
my favourite toy was that pistol thing
with the boomerang on the front doesn't
really matter what color you get as long
as you like your gun I don't really care
which color it is when I go buy a toy I
usually see if I like the model of the
toy no you're not here if it's big girls
like guidance - it's not just boys
you